GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER PLEASE BE
ADVISED AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BE MADE AS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED BOTTOM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HERE
THERE YEAH. YEAH GREAT STUFF
THERE YEAH YEAH MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS YOUR. VERY PRETTY MUCH.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSIDERED LET ME NOTE THAT
THE- EARLIER THIS OF THE GENDER
WHICH INCLUDED THE ADDITIONAL
NURSING PAUSED TO S. B. NINE
NINE NINE NINE FIVE ATKINS HAS
BEEN ALTERED THAT IS NO LONGER
ON THE AGENDA SO EVERY SINGLE
ITEM REQUEST TO WAIVE JOINT
RULE SIXTY ONE B. SEVENTEEN FOR
SB FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
MOVED BY OF MISS CRUZ SECONDED
BY MS COM LONGER. OF
MANUFACTURE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HI. I. FIVE FIVE. RIGHT
REYES AND I FOUND HI KAMLAGER I
MEAN FOR I THINK AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I. FIVE FIVE. MOTIONS
FOR AND THE RULES IS A GERMAN
THANK YOU MUCH.